c'est à votre avis quel est ce produit
déjà en colère pourquoi un truc vidéo un
écran non partie des ces la pâte à
tartiner
voici la bassée minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ils étaient des millions et
des millions elle est détruite et de la
cua la pâte à tartiner
on aurait dit la guerre bah oui c'est
vrai faire alors et combien cela coûte t
nutella un programme où le pot un petit
bo un petit pot le plot de l'autre par
la matinée de 950 g 4 50 à 54 70 et là
il y avait une remise 70 % de remise un
neuro 41 ans les gens se sont bousculés
et ont couru dans tous les sens on a des
images
regardez c'est l'émeute pour du nutella
ouais je croyais qu'il y avait une
nouvelle halle à leur smartphone qui
était petit sans nom et je voyais juste
les garçons les gars dirait qu'il
sortait tout ce koh lanta mon frère
dernier affable
[Musique]
non ce n'est pas normal
on diminue la presse
mais non et en comparant à la projo a
été fort à l'époque la promo je
comprends voilà que les gens y soient
les méchas fait des émules
oui il ya des mômes qui sont vraiment a
dit que ce prince produits faut c'est un
drame dont il a face à l'émeute
le magasin a obligé les gens à ne pas
acheter plus de 3 po maximum
merci à graulhet oui mais il ya des gens
pour qui cette promotion ça fait faire
des vraies économies mais bon on est
content 3 0 c'est bien sûr pour des gens
aussi vraiment mais je trouve on leur
réserve il achète 3 p c'est vrai que les
images sont impressionnantes